The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're going
to be talking about games.
And I know you guys as
well as I hope I do.
The main thing that you guys
want to talk about with games
is how to do that
alpha-beta thing.
Because it's pretty confusing.
And it's easy to get lost
in a corner or something.
Whereas doing the regular
minimax, in my experience,
most 6034 students can do that.
And they do it right
pretty much all the time.
However, we're going to focus
on all the different components
of games.
And I put up two provocative
silver star ideas
up on the board, which
will come into play here.
The Snow White
principle is a new name.
And it has never been
revealed until today.
Because I made up name recently.
So you will be the first
people to hear it and decide
if it works better than
the term "grandfather
clause" for the thing that
I'm trying to describe.
Because most grandfathers
don't eat their children.
So here we've got a
beautiful game tree.
It has nodes from
A through R. This
is our standard
game tree from 6034.
We've got a maximizer
up at the top
who's trying to get the
highest score possible.
The minimizer is her opponent.
And the minimizer is trying
to get to the lowest score
possible.
And it's really unclear who
wins or loses at each point.
They're just trying to get it
to the highest or the lowest
score.
All right, so let's
do a refresher.
Hopefully the quiz didn't put
people into such panic modes
that they forgot
Monday's lecture.
So let's make sure that
we can do regular minimax
algorithm on this tree
and figure out the minimax
value at A.
So let's see how that works.
All right, as you guys
remember, the game search
when using regular
minimax is essentially
a depth first search.
And at each level, it
chooses between all
of the children whichever
value that the parent wants.
So here after it would choose
the maximum of K and L,
for instance.
But that's getting
ahead of ourselves.
Because it's a
depth first search.
So we best start at the top.
I'll help you guys
up for a while.
So we're doing A. We
need the maximum of B, C,
D, depth first search.
We go to B. We're looking
for the minimum of E and F.
So having looked at E, our
current minimum of E and F
is just 2 for the moment.
So this is going to be
less than or equal to 2.
All right, then we go down
to F, which is a maximizer.
And its children are
K and L. So now I'm
going to start making
you guys do stuff.
So what do you think?
What is going to be
the minimax value at F?
The minimax value at
F, what will that be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So that level is
a maximizer-- max, min, max.
F is a maximizer.
K and L themselves
are minimizers.
But they're pretty
impotent minimizers.
Because they don't
get to choose.
They just have to do K or L.
So the minimax value is three.
And yeah, the path it
would like to go is K.
So we'll say that the
minimax value here is 3.
It's in fact exactly equal to 3.
So if this is 3 and this
is 2, then everyone,
we know that the value of B is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I hear 3 and 2.
Which one is it?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2, that's right.
So the value here is 2.
Great, let's go down
into this branch.
So C is going to be
the minimum of G and 6.
But we don't see that yet.
Because we're doing
a depth first search.
It's going to be
the minimum of G.
Now we need the
maximum of M and N.
We're going to need the minimum.
M is the minimum of Q and
R. So let's switch sides.
The minimum of Q and R is?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
That's right, it's 1.
So M has a value of 1.
But I'm going to stay over here.
Because M has a value of 1.
Knowing that, then we know
that G has a value of?
AUDIENCE: 7
PROFESSOR: That's right.
7 is higher than 1.
And since G is a 7, we
now know going up to C
that C has a value of?
AUDIENCE: 6.
PROFESSOR: Yes, C
has a value of 6.
That's the minimum 6 and 7.
So now I'm going
to go back down.
Because we've done one
of the other sub-trees.
This is a 6.
All right, great.
Now we're going to go down to D.
Hopefully it won't be too bad.
These things usually
aren't terrible.
Because they're made to be
pruned a lot in alpha-beta.
So let's see, in D, we go down
to I. And that's just a 1.
We go down to J. And let's see,
what's the minimax value of J?
AUDIENCE: It's 20.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
20 is the maximum of 20 and 2.
Great, so what's the
minimax value of D?
Everyone said it-- 1.
All right, so what's
the minimax value at A?
AUDIENCE: 6.
PROFESSOR: 6 is right.
6 is higher than 2.
It's higher than 1.
Our value is 6.
And our path is-- everyone--
A, C, H. That's it.
Great, is everyone
good with minimax?
I know that usually
a lot of people are.
There's usually a few
people who aren't.
So if you're one
of the people who
would like some clarifications
on minimax, raise your hand.
There's probably a few other
people who would like some too.
OK.
AUDIENCE: When you're doing
this minimax, whatever values
are not showing, you
keep going down the tree
and then just look
at whether you're
trying to find the minimax.
And just whatever values
you get you go back up one?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The question was, when you go
to do the minimax-- and let's
say you got E was
2, and you know
that B is going to be
less than or equal to 2,
but you don't know F yet.
The question is, do you go down
the tree, find the value at F,
and then go back up?
The answer is yes.
By default, we use a
depth first search.
However, in non alpha-beta
version, just regular minimax,
it turns out it probably
doesn't matter what you do.
I suggested doing a depth
first search to get yourself
in the mindset of alpha-beta.
Because order is very, very
important in alpha-beta.
But here, I don't know, you
could do some weird bottom
up search.
Whatever you want, it's going
to give you the right answer
unless it asks what
order they evaluated.
But here's a hint.
The order they're evaluated in
is depth first search order.
So without even doing anything,
E, K, L, Q, R, N, H, I, O, P
are the order of starting
evaluation in this tree.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question
is, nodes like M and G
we don't have to
put values next to.
Technically, if we were
doing this very formally,
and we couldn't
remember, and I wasn't
up there among the people,
we would put 1 there.
So at M, we would put a 1.
But people remembered that.
So we didn't do it.
But then at G, we would put a 7.
So if we were writing
it out very formally,
we would have a 1 and a 7.
And at this D, we
would have a 1.
And then at the A,
we would put a 6.
And then that's the answer.
Also, we've even put things
like less than or greater
than part way along the way.
However, I believe that
our alpha-beta search
is going to definitely
fulfill everyone's quota
of pedantically putting lots
of numbers next to nodes
on a game tree.
And so once you've
done alpha-beta,
if you can do it
correctly, you'll
think, oh, minimax, oh,
those were the days.
It's going to be easy.
Because alpha-beta is a
little bit more complicated.
There's a lot of things
that trip people up here.
For alpha-beta,
however, I will erase
some of these numbers
for the moment.
They're still right.
But we do it a
little differently.
So what do alpha-beta and
beta add to this formula?
Well, this is all sort
of a winning formula,
except for it's not.
Because it takes too long.
But it's a very nice formula.
U is the maximizer, say.
I would try to think, if I do
this, what's he going to do?
And then if he does that,
what am I going to do?
And then what is
he going to do if I
do that, et cetera, et cetera,
all the way to the bottom.
With alpha and
beta, we add in what
I like to call nuclear options.
I'd like in this game
of maximizer minimizer--
you can think of it as like the
Cold War or the Peloponnesian
War, except the Peloponnesian
War didn't have nukes, so
probably the Cold War.
And in the Cold War,
or any situation
where you're up against an
adversary who-- actually,
this doesn't really work
as well for the Cold War.
But in any situation
where you're
up against an adversary
whose only goal in life
is to destroy you,
you always want
to find out what the best
thing you can possibly do
is if they hit that button
and send nukes in from Cuba,
or if they send fighter pilots,
or whatever is going on.
So the idea of alpha
and beta is that they
are numbers that represent
the fail-safe, the worst case.
Because obviously
in the Cold War,
sending nukes was
not a good plan.
But presumably, us
sending nukes would
be better than just being
attacked and killed.
So the alpha and beta represent
the worst possible outcome
you'd be willing to
accept for your side.
Because right now,
you know you're
guaranteed to be able to force
the conflict to that point
or better.
So the alpha is the nuclear
option, the fail-safe,
of the maximizer.
Nuclear options-- alpha is
maximizer's nuclear option.
And beta is the
minimizer's nuclear option.
So we ask ourselves-- and
people who were paying attention
at lecture or wrote stuff
down know the answer already--
what could we possibly
set to start off?
Before we explore the
tree and find anything,
what will we set as
our nuclear option,
as our sort of fail-safe?
We could always fall
back on this number.
So you could set 0.
You could try to set some
low number for the maximizer.
Because if you set a high
number for the maximizer
as its fail-safe, it's going to
be really snooty and just say,
oh, I won't take this path.
I already have a
fail-safe that's
better than all these paths.
If you set, like,
100, you have no tree.
Our default usually, in 6034,
is to set negative infinity
for alpha or negative some very
large number if you're doing it
in your lab.
So if we set negative infinity
as a default for alpha,
that negative infinity is
basically maximizer loses.
So the maximizer
goes in thinking,
oh my god, if I don't
look at this game tree,
I automatically lose.
He's willing to take the
first path possibly presented.
And that's why that
negative infinity
is a good default for alpha.
Anyone have a good idea
what a good default for beta
is, or just remember?
Positive infinity, that's right.
Because the minimizer comes
in, and she's like, oh crap,
the maximizer automatically wins
if I don't look at this node
here.
That makes sure the
maximizer and the minimizer
both are willing to look at the
first path they see every time.
Because look on this tree.
If 10 was alpha, the
maximizer would just
reject out of hand
everything except for P.
And then we wouldn't
have a tree.
The maximizer would lose,
because he would be like, hmm,
this test game is
very interesting.
However, I have
another option-- pft,
and then you throw
over the table.
That's 10 for me, because you
have to pick up the pieces.
I don't own this set.
I don't know.
So that is why we set negative
infinity and positive infinity
as the default for
alpha and beta.
So how do alpha
and beta propagate?
And what do they do?
The main purpose of alpha
and beta is that, as we said,
alpha-- let's say we have
some chart of values.
Alpha, which starts
at negative infinity,
is the worst that the
maximizer is willing to accept.
Because they know they can
get that much or better.
It starts out, that's the
worst thing you can have.
So it's not a problem.
Infinity is the highest that the
minimizer is willing to accept.
That's beta.
As you go along,
though, the minimizer
sees, oh, look at that.
I can guarantee that at
best the maximizer gets 100.
Haha, beta is now 100.
The maximizer says, oh yeah?
Well I can guarantee that the
lowest you can get me to go to
is 0.
So it's going to be 0.
And this keeps going on
until maybe at 6-- note,
not drawn to scale.
Maybe at 6, the
maximizer said, haha,
you can't make me
go lower than 6.
And the minimizer says, aha, you
can't make me go higher than 6.
And then 6 is the answer.
If you ever get to a point where
beta gets lower than alpha,
or alpha gets lower than beta,
then you just say, screw this.
I'm not even going to look
at the remaining stuff.
I'm going to just prune now
and go somewhere else that's
less pointless than this.
Because if the alpha gets higher
than the beta, what that's
saying is the maximizer says,
oh man, look at this, minimizer.
The lowest you can
make me go is, say, 50.
And the minimizer
says, that's strange.
Because the highest that
you can make me go is 40.
So something's
generally amiss there.
It usually means that
one of the two of them
doesn't even want to be
exploring that branch at all.
So you prune at that point.
All right, so given that
that's what we're looking for,
how do we move the alphas and
betas throughout the tree?
There's a few different
ways to draw them.
And some of them I
consider to be very busy.
Probably in recitation
and tutorial
you will see a way that's
busier and has more numbers.
Technically, every node has
both an alpha and a beta.
However, the one that that
node is paying attention to
is the alpha, if
it's a maximizer,
and the beta if
it's a minimizer.
So I generally, for my purposes,
only draw the alpha out
for the maximizer and only draw
the beta out for the minimizer.
Very rarely, but it happens,
they'll sometimes ask you,
well, what's the beta
of this node, which
is a maximizer node?
So it's good to know
how it's derived.
But I think that it wastes
your time to write it out.
That's my opinion.
We'll see how it goes.
So the way that it works, the
way that alpha and beta works,
is the Snow White principal.
So does everyone know
the story of Snow White?
So there's a beautiful princess.
There's an evil
queen stepmother.
Mirror mirror on the wall,
who's the fairest of them all,
finds out that it's
the stepdaughter.
So much like in the real
world, in Snow White,
the stepdaughter, Snow White,
had the beauty of her parents.
She inherited those.
However, much like in
the real world, maybe
or perhaps not, the stepmother
had an even better plan.
She hired a hunter to
sort of hunt Snow White,
pull out Snow White's
heart, and feed it
to her so that she
could gain Snow White's
beauty for herself.
How many people knew that
version of the story?
A few people.
That's the original
version of the story.
Disney didn't put that in.
The hunter then
brought the heart
of a deer, which I think in
Disney the hunter did kill
a deer arbitrarily,
but it was not
explained that that's
why he was doing it.
So in alpha-beta,
it's just like that.
By which I mean you start
by inheriting the alpha
and beta of your parents.
But if you see something that
you like amongst your children,
you take it for yourself--
the Snow White principle.
So let's see how that goes.
Well, I told you guys that
the default alpha was--
AUDIENCE: Negative infinity.
PROFESSOR: Negative infinity.
So here alpha is
negative infinity.
And I told you that the default
beta was positive infinity.
We're doing a depth
first search here.
All right, beta is infinity.
All right, so we come here to
E. Now, we could put an alpha.
But I never put
an alpha or a beta
for one of the terminal nodes.
Because it can't
really do anything.
It's just 2.
So as we go down, we
take the alpha and beta
from our parents.
But as we go up to a
parent, if the parent likes
what it sees in the child,
it takes it instead.
So I ask you all the
question, would the minimizer
prefer this 2 that it sees from
its child or its own infinity
for a beta?
AUDIENCE: 2
PROFESSOR: It likes the 2.
That's absolutely right.
So 2.
All right, great, so now we go
down to F. What is F's alpha?
Who says negative infinity?
Who says 2?
No one-- oh, you guys are good.
It's negative infinity.
Technically, it also
will have a beta of 2.
But we're ignoring the beta.
And the alphas that have
been progressing downward
from the parents--
negative infinity.
That's why I called it the
grandfather clause before.
Because you would often look up
to your grandparent to see what
your default number is.
So we get an alpha
of negative infinity.
We then go down to the K.
It's a static evaluation.
And now I'm going to start
calling on people individually.
So hopefully people
paid attention
to the mob, who
were always correct.
All right, so we go down
to K. And we see a 3.
F is a maximizer node.
So what does F do now?
AUDIENCE: Switches
its alpha to 3.
PROFESSOR: Yes, switches
its alpha to 3, great.
All right, so that's
already quite good.
It switches alpha to 3.
It's very happy.
It's got a 3 here.
That's a nice value.
So what does it do
at L, the next node?
It's gone to K, went
back up to F. Depth
first search, the next
one would be L, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, technically
F could take L's value of 0
if it liked it better than 3.
But it's a maximizer.
So does it want to take that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, that
technically would be correct.
But I'm sorry.
I burdened you with
a trick question.
In fact, we don't
look at L at all.
Does everyone see that?
I'll explain.
The alpha at F has reached 3.
But the beta at B is 2.
So B looks down and
says, wait a minute.
If I go down to F, my
enemy's nuclear option,
my enemy is the worst it
can be for-- the best it
can be for me is 3.
F is trumpeting it around.
I was thinking of eating
his heart, or whatever,
but I didn't want to.
But it's going to be 3.
It's going to be 3 or
higher down there at F.
There's no way I want that.
I already have my own
default escape plan.
And that's 2.
That's going to be better
than whatever comes out
of that horrible F. So screw it.
And we never look at L.
Does everyone get that?
That is the main principle
of alpha-beta pruning.
If you see an alpha that's
higher than the beta above it--
as I said, if alpha
goes up above the beta--
or if you see a beta, like
if there's a beta down here,
and it's lower than the
alpha above it, prune it.
Stop doing that.
And the question is, who prunes?
Who decides that
you don't look at L?
The person who is
thinking not to look at L
is always up higher by
at least two levels.
So up here, B is
saying, hmm, I don't
want to look at L. Because F
is already so terrible for me
that it's just beyond belief.
If this is 100, it might be 100.
Even if it's lower, I'm
still going to get a three.
There's a sanity check that
I've written that I sort of came
up with just in case you're
not sure that you can skip it.
Because on a lot of
these tests, we ask you,
which one's do you evaluate,
which ones do you skip, right?
Or we just say, which
ones do you evaluate,
and you don't write
the ones that you skip.
Here's my sanity test to
see if you can skip it.
Ask yourself, if
that node that I'm
about to skip contained
a negative infinity
or some arbitrarily small
number, negative infinity
being the minimizer wins,
would it change anything?
Now that I've
answered that, if it
contained a positive infinity,
would it change anything?
If the answer is no
both times, then you're
definitely correct
in pruning it.
So look at that 0.
If it was a negative
infinity, minimizer wins,
what would happen?
The maximizer would say, I'm
not touching that was a 10 foot
pole, choosing 3.
The minimizer would say,
screw that, I'll take E.
Let's say it was a
positive infinity.
The maximizer would say,
eureka, holy grain, I win.
The minimizer would say,
yeah, if I'm a moron,
and go down to F, and then
would go to E and take 2.
So no matter what was there,
the minimizer would go to E.
And you could say, well,
what if it was exactly 2?
But still the
maximizer would choose
K. The minimizer would
go to E. So there's
no reason to go down there.
We can just prune
it off right now.
Does everyone
agree, everyone see
what I'm talking about here?
Great, so we're now
done with this branch.
Because beta is 2.
So now we're up at
old grandpappy A.
And he has an alpha
of negative infinity.
Everyone, what will he do?
He'll take the 2.
It's better than negative
infinity for him.
It's not wonderful.
But certainly anything is
better than an automatic loss.
All right, now our
highest node is a 2.
So let's keep that in
mind for our alpha.
OK, so let's go over here.
Let's see, so what
will be the value at C?
What will be the beta value?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You go
back to which one?
To G. I'm not at G yet.
I'm actually just starting
the middle branch.
So I'm going to C. And what's
going to be its starting
beta before I go down?
AUDIENCE: Infinity.
PROFESSOR: Infinity, that's
right-- default value.
It's easier than it seemed.
All right, so yes, beta
is equal to infinity.
This should be better erased.
I think it's confusing people.
Great, OK, so beta is
equal to infinity at C.
Now we go down depth
first search to G. What's
going to be our alpha at G?
AUDIENCE: Minus infinity.
PROFESSOR: Ahh,
it would seem so.
However, take a look up
at the great-grandpappy A.
It seems to have changed to 2.
So this time it's 2.
Why is it 2 instead
of negative infinity?
Why can we let A be so noxious
and not start with saying,
oh, I automatically lose?
Well, A knows that no
matter how awful things get
in that middle branch,
he can just say,
screw the whole middle branch.
I'm going to B.
That's something that
the minimizer can't do.
And we have to start at
infinity for the minimizer.
But the maximizer can.
Because he has the
choice at the top.
Does everyone see that?
He can just say, oh, I'm
not even going to C. Yeah,
shows you.
I'm going to A and taking the 2.
So therefore alpha
is actually 2 at G.
All right, great, so
we've got an alpha that's
2 at G. We're going to go
down to M. It's a minimizer.
All right, what's going
to be our beta value at M?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Or which is
the beta default, minus
or positive infinity?
What would be the minimizer?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
PROFESSOR: Positive
infinity, that's right.
M is going to be a
positive infinity for beta.
Again, it picks it
up from C. Great,
now we get to some
actual values.
So we're at some actual values.
We are at Q. So
what's going to happen
at M when M sees that Q is 1?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What is beta?
It says infinity.
I'm sorry, it's hard to read.
Beta is infinity at M.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's
going to minimize, right?
So it's going to be
like, OK, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So they're going
to put beta to 1.
Because it sees Q. Great,
so my next question is,
what's going to happen at R?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very smart.
You've detected my trap.
The question is,
does it look at R?
The answer is, no.
It doesn't look at R.
Why doesn't it look at R?
Does everyone see?
Yeah, alpha is now greater
than the beta below it.
Beta has gotten
lower than alpha.
This is the same thing I
was talking about before,
when we figured out that
the alpha here is 2.
The maximizer says,
wait a minute.
The maximizer G says, if I go
to M, the best I'm getting out
of this is 1.
Because if this is
negative infinity,
the minimizer will choose it.
If this is positive
infinity, he'll choose 1.
The best I'm going to
get out of here is 1.
If that's the case, I might
as well have just gone
to B and not even gone to C.
So I'm not going to go to M.
I'll go to N, maybe.
Maybe N is better.
Does everyone see that?
Great, so let's say that
the maximizer does go to N.
So what's going to
happen with this alpha?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right,
it's going to be 7.
7 is better than 2.
And the maximizer has
control to get to that seven,
at least if it gets to G. All
right, now the minimizer at C--
we'll do everyone this time.
The minimizer at C, seeing that
7, what does the minimizer do?
Anyone?
So it sees the 7.
What does it do to its beta?
It takes the 7-- better
than infinity, anyway.
And yeah, then it checks H.
And everybody, again, what
happens at H?
It takes the 6.
It's lower than 7.
All right, now we'll
go back to having
people do it on their own.
Well, all the way
back to the top,
what does A do when it
sees the 6 coming out of C?
AUDIENCE: Changes to 6.
PROFESSOR: Changes
to 6, that's right.
Alpha equals 6.
Great-- homestretch,
people, homestretch.
So the minimizer, everyone,
has a beta of infinity.
And if I wasn't a static node,
it would have an alpha of 6.
But it is a static node.
So it just has a value of 1.
So since it has a value of 1,
everyone, the beta becomes 1.
And what next, everyone?
AUDIENCE: Prune.
PROFESSOR: Prune, that's right.
Why prune?
Well, this time it's A
himself who can prune.
A says, well darn,
if I go to D, I'm
going to get 1 or something
even worse than 1.
I might as well take
my 6 while I have it,
prune all the rest
all the way down.
Everyone see that?
Everyone cool with that?
It's not too bad if you
take it one step at a time.
We did it.
Our question is, which nodes
are evaluated in order?
Our answer is, everyone-- E, K,
Q, N, H, I. OK, not so obvious,
I guess.
A few people followed me.
But it is E, K, Q, N, H, I.
It's just depth first order.
And we pruned some of them away.
Great, so that is alpha-beta.
Any questions about that
before I give some questions
about progressive deepening?
All right, we've got a bunch.
So first question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
nodes like F, B, C, and D?
PROFESSOR: The
question is, when asked
for the order of evaluation,
are we excluding F, B, C, and D?
The answer is we're talking
about here static evaluation.
The static evaluator is a
very important and interesting
function.
And I'll get back to something
a few students have asked me
about the static evaluator later
and try to explain what it is.
It's basically the thing
that pops out those numbers
at the bottom of the leaves.
So when we ask, what
is the order of nodes
that were statically
evaluated, we mean leaves only.
That's a good question.
Any other questions?
Let's see, there was
one up here before.
But it's gone.
It might have been the same one.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So a similar question.
When you say, static nodes,
that just means the leaf nodes?
PROFESSOR: Means the
leaf nodes, that's right.
The question is, does static
nodes mean the leaf nodes.
The answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: And so
static evaluation
is when you compare the value
of a static node to something?
PROFESSOR: Static
evaluation is when you get
that number, the static node.
Let me explain.
Unless someone else has another
question about alpha-beta,
let me explain static values.
Because I was about to do that.
There is a question
about alpha-beta.
I'll come back to both of
yours after I answer this.
AUDIENCE: You were
mentioning [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm a little bit confused.
If you're looking at
one node, and you're
seeing either grab the
value from the grandparent
or grab it from the--
PROFESSOR: So it always
starts-- the question is, what
is the Snow White principle?
How does it work?
Every node always
starts off with taking
the value of the same
type, alpha or beta,
from its grandparent.
It always starts that way.
Now, you say, why
the grandparent?
Wouldn't it take
it from the parent?
It actually does.
But I'm not drawing out the
alphas at all the minimizer
levels.
Because they don't do anything.
They're only even there
to pass them down.
So all of the values pass
down, down, down, down, down
to begin.
Every node, in fact, starts
off with its grandparents
with its parents' values, OK?
But then when the
node sees a child,
it's completely done evaluating.
It's finished.
It can't be in the process.
Let's say C. When C sees
that G is completely
done with all of
its sub-branches
and is ready to return
a value, or if it's just
a static evaluation, then it's
automatically completely done.
Because it has no children.
A static value like K of 3 is
automatically completely done.
It's got a 3.
Similarly, when we came
back to G after going to N,
and we knew that the value was
7, that was completely done.
The value was definitely 7.
There was no other
possibilities.
AUDIENCE: That's after looking
at the children, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So once you're done with
all the children of G,
then G comes up and
says, guess what?
Guess what, guys?
So technically before
that, you would
have said that G's alpha is
greater than or equal to 1
when we looked at Q. And then
we looked at M. We'd say,
it's equal exactly to 7.
We're done here.
And then at that point,
when it's fresh and ripe
and has all of its highest
value or its best value,
that's when the parent can eat
its heart and gain that value
itself.
So that's when C says,
for instance, oh man,
I have an infinity.
I really like that 7 better.
And it takes the 7.
But then it saw H. And it
said, oh man, that's a 6.
That's even better than 7.
So it took the 6.
AUDIENCE: So shouldn't
the alpha take 7 then?
PROFESSOR: So alpha takes 6.
Because C is a minimizer.
C took the 7 from
G, but then right
after that C saw
H and took the 6.
Because 6 is even lower than 7.
And then alpha took the 6.
Because 6 was higher than 2.
AUDIENCE: So it's not going
to look below the branch?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the problem
is that the maximizer doesn't
have control there.
The minimizer has
got control at C.
And the minimizer
is going to make
sure it's as low as possible.
The maximizer at A, his only
control, or her only control,
is the ability to send
either way to B or C
or D. And then at
that point, at C,
the minimizer gets to
choose if we go to G or H.
And it's never going to choose
G. Because G is higher than H.
All right, awesome, was
there another question?
All right, let's go back
to static evaluations.
When I first took this class,
I had some weird thoughts
about static evolutions.
I heard some
students ask me this.
I almost got a question about
it onto one of the tests,
but it was edited to some
other weird question that
was m to the b to the
d minus 1 or something
like that at the last minute.
So I'm going to pose you
guys the actual question that
would have been on one
of the older test, which
is the following.
I had a student who came
to me and said, you know,
[INAUDIBLE], when we do this
alpha-beta pruning, and all
this other stuff, we're trying
to assume that we're really
saving that much
time by getting rid
of a few static evaluations.
In fact, when we do
progressive deepening,
we're always just counting,
how many static evaluations
do we have to do?
And he said, I look at
these static evaluations.
And there's just a 3 there.
It takes no time to do
the static evaluation.
It's on the board.
It takes much longer
to do the alpha-beta.
It's faster by far
to not do alpha-beta.
So I then tried to
explain to that student.
I said, OK, we need
to be clear about what
static evaluations are.
You guys get it easy.
We put these numbers
on the board.
A static evaluation--
let's say you're
playing a game like chess.
Static evaluation
takes a long time.
When I was in 6170,
Java [INAUDIBLE],
the class that used to
exist, we had a program
called Anti-Chess where I used
my 6034 skills to write the AI.
And the static evaluator
took a long time.
And we were timed.
So getting the static
evaluator faster,
that was the most
important thing.
Why does it take a long time?
Well, the static
evaluator is an evaluation
of the board position,
the state of the game,
at a snapshot of time.
And that's not as easy as just
saying, oh, here's the answer.
Because in chess,
first of all, not only
did I have to look at
how many pieces I had,
what areas that I controlled.
Also-- well, it was anti-chess.
But that's not withstanding.
Let's pretend it's
regular chess.
I also had to look, if
it was in regular chess--
and I still had to do
this in anti-chess--
if my king was in check.
And what that meant
is I had to look
at all of my opponent's
moves, possible moves,
to see if anyone of
them could take my king.
Because in regular chess,
it's illegal to put your king
into check.
So you better not
even allow that move.
And regardless,
getting into checkmate
is negative infinity for you.
So it takes a really long
time to do static evaluations,
at least good ones, usually.
You want to avoid them.
Because they're not just
some number on the page.
They are some function
you wrote that does
a very careful analysis of the
state of the game and says,
I'm good to heuristically
guess that my value is
pi, or some other
number, and then rates
that compared to other states.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
So the answer to the
hypothetical question
that might have been
on the old test, when
the person said, I've got this
great idea where you do tons
of static evaluation,
and you don't
have to do this long
alpha-beta, is, don't do that.
The static evaluations
actually take a long time.
Does that clear it up
for people who asked me
before about what is a static
evaluation, why are the leaf
nodes called static?
And you might ask, why are
some of these static just
arbitrarily?
The answer is, when you're
running out of time to expand
deeper, and you just need to
stop that stage of the game--
maybe it's just
getting too hairy,
maybe it's spreading
out too much,
you have some
heuristic that says,
this is where I
stop for now-- it's
a heuristic guess of the value.
It's kind of like those
heuristic values in the search
tree.
It's a guess of
how much work you
have left to get to the goal.
Here, you say, well, I
wish I could go deeper.
But I just don't have the time.
So here's how I think
I'm doing at this level.
It's not always right.
And that's going to
lead us into the answer
to one of the questions
about progressive deepening.
So I'll put up the
progressive deepening
question really quickly.
So the question is this.
Let me see, this is
a maximizer-- yes.
Suppose that we do progressive
deepening on the tree that
is only two levels deep.
What is progressive deepening
in a nutshell if you don't
remember from the lecture?
The idea is this.
In this tree, it doesn't work.
But in trees that actually
branch like 2 to the n,
it doesn't take that much time
to do some of the top levels
first and then move on
to the bottom levels.
Just do them one at a time.
So let's say we only did it
up through J. We only did
the top two levels of the tree.
We'd like to reorder the
tree so that alpha-beta
can prune as much as it
possibly can, at least we hope.
So let's pretend that we
had a psychic awesome genius
friend who told us that the
static values when we went up
to two levels-- remember,
when we go to two levels,
F, G, and J have to get
a static value, right?
Because we're not going down.
We do a static evaluation.
They get the exact correct
numbers-- 3, 7, and 20.
Genius, brilliant.
All right, so if
that happens, what
is the best way that we
could reorder that tree?
Oh yeah, so it's A, B, C, D with
values of 2, 3, 7, 6, 1, 20.
I'll draw that.
This is the non-reordered tree.
Let's see, so it's
2, 3, 7, 6, 1, 20.
So what's the best
way to reorder?
Well, first of all,
does anyone remember
what Patrick said when he talked
about progressive deepening?
Usually no one does, so
don't worry about it.
Because at that time
you guys didn't think,
oh, I have to do
this for the quiz.
You were just
thinking, oh man, we've
already heard alpha-beta
and all this other stuff.
And this is just a small fact.
But it's a very important fact.
And now you know you have
to do it for the quiz.
So you're probably
going to remember it.
The way you do it is you
try to guess, and you say,
which one of these is
going to be a winner?
Whichever one I think is going
to be a winner at that level,
I put first.
Why is that the case?
Well, something interesting
you may have noticed here--
whenever you have a winner,
like the middle node,
or whenever you have
whatever is the current best
for your alpha, you sort
of have to explore out
a lot of that area.
Like for instance, the left
node was our current best at 2.
The middle branch
was our current best,
at that time was 6.
It was the total best.
We had to explore a
good number of nodes.
But on the right, we
just saw, oh, there's 1.
We're done.
We cut everything off.
In other words, the
branch that turns out
to be the one that
you take, you have
to do a pretty good
amount of exploration
to prove that it's
the right one.
Whereas if it's
the wrong one, you
can sometimes with just one
node say, this is wrong, done.
So therefore, if the
one that turns out
to be the eventual
winner is first of all,
then it's really easy to
reject all the other branches.
Do people see that sort of
conceptually a little bit,
that if you get the
best node right away,
you can just reject all the
wrong ones pretty quickly?
That's our goal.
So how can we, quote, "get
the right one," the best one
right away?
Well, here's how we do it.
Let's say we're at B. Which one
is the minimizer likely to pick
assuming that our
heuristic is good
and that these guesses are
pretty much close to the truth?
It turns out they're perfect,
so this is going to work.
So which one will
the minimizer pick
if it has to choose between
E and F, do we think?
AUDIENCE: E.
PROFESSOR: E, perfect.
Which one will it
pick between G and H?
AUDIENCE: H.
PROFESSOR: H. Which one will
it pick between I and J?
AUDIENCE: I.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
what we're saying
is we think it's
going to pick E.
We think it's going to pick H.
We think it's going to pick I.
So first of all, we should
put E before F, H before G,
and I before J. Because we think
it's going to pick those first.
Those are probably our best ones
to invalidate a poor branch.
So now between 2,
6, and 1, which
is what we think we're going
to get, which one do we think
the maximizer is going to take?
AUDIENCE: 6.
PROFESSOR: 6.
Then if it couldn't take 6, what
would be its next best choice?
2, then 1.
That's just our
order-- simple as that.
It couldn't be
anything easier that
evolves really complex trees,
a huge number of numbers,
and reordering those trees.
So C-- you guys told me C, B,
D. You told me C, B, D, I think?
Yeah, those are the ones
the maximizer likes.
And then the ones the minimizer
likes you told me was H,
and before G. Because
H is smaller than G.
You guys told me E before F.
And you guys told me I before J.
And you guys would be
correct in all regards.
We have 6, 7, 2, 3, 1, 20.
All the minimizers choose
from smallest to highest.
The maximizer chooses from
highest to lowest of the ones
that the minimizers will take.
And if we did that, you
can see we would probably
save some time.
Let's see how much time.
Let's say we looked at H first.
Well, if we looked
at H first, we
would still have actually had
to look at Q and N. However,
we would not have had to
look at K. Do people see why?
If we already knew
this branch was 6,
as soon as we saw 2 for the
beta here-- 2 is less than 6--
we could have pruned.
We still would have had
to look at I over here.
Because you have to
look at at least one
thing in the new sub-branch.
And it actually only would
have saved us one node-- oops.
So it winds up that in
total, how many nodes would
we have evaluated if we did that
little scheme of reordering?
Well, we normally had to
do six-- E, K, Q, N, H, I.
How many do we evaluate if we
do this progressive deepening
scheme?
How many times do we run
the static evaluator,
which of course you know
the static evaluator takes
a long time?
Anyone have a guess?
I told you the only one we don't
evaluate is K. Raise your hand.
I won't make anyone
give this one.
So I said the only
one we save on is K.
So we still do E, Q,
N, H, and I over here.
There's two possible
answers that I will accept.
So you have a higher
chance of guessing it.
Anyway?
Does everyone agree
that we did six before?
If we didn't do any
progressive deepening,
we just did E, K, Q, N, H, I.
And now we're not doing K. OK,
people are saying five.
All right, good.
That's not the right answer.
But it at least shows that you
can do taking away the one.
We did at least five over here.
There's two possible
answers, though.
Because look over there.
In order to do the
progressive deepening,
we had to do those static
evaluations, right?
So we either did all
those static evaluations
and these five-- E, K, Q, N,
H, I-- static evaluations.
Because we didn't do the K.
Or we might have
saved ourselves.
Because maybe we were
smart and decided
to cache the static values when
we were going down the tree.
It's an implementation detail
that on this test when we asked
that question we didn't say.
What I mean by cache is
when we did it here and saw
that E was a 2, and
then here-- oh, we
have to do the static value
at E. If we were smart,
we might have made a little
hash table or something
and put down 2 so we didn't have
to do a static evaluation at E.
And if that happened,
well, we save E, H, and I,
and we do three fewer.
Does everyone see that?
However, that's
still more than six.
So it didn't save us time.
So you might say, oh,
progressive deepening
is a waste of time.
But it's not.
Because this is a very, very
small, not very branchy tree
that was made so that
you guys could easily
do alpha-beta and take the
quiz, and it wouldn't be bad.
If this was actually branching
even double at each level,
it would have, what, 16 nodes
down here at the bottom.
Then you would want to be doing
that progressive deepening.
So now I ask you a
conceptual riddle question.
It's not really that
much of a riddle.
But we'll see if
anyone wants to answer.
Again, I won't call
on you for this.
According to this
test, a student
named Steve says,
OK, I know I have
to pay to do the
progressive deepening here.
But let's ignore that.
Because it's small in
a large tree, right?
It's not going to
take that much.
Let's ignore the costs of
the progressive deepening
and only look at
how much we do here.
He says, when it comes to
performing the alpha-beta
on the final level,
I'm guaranteed
to always prune at
least as well or better
if I rearrange the nodes
based on the best result
from progressive deepening.
Do you agree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Can I repeat it?
OK, the question is,
ignoring the cost
that we pay progressively
deepening here-- just
forget about it-- at the final
step, at the final iteration,
the question is, am I
guaranteed to do at least as
well or better in my
alpha-beta pruning
when I reorder based
on the best order
for progressive deepening?
Here certainly we did.
But the question is,
is Steve guaranteed?
Answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What did you say?
PROFESSOR: That's the
answer and the why,
which we asked to explain.
The answer we got is, doesn't
that depend on the heuristic?
Perfectly correct.
The answer is, no,
we're not guaranteed,
and it depends on the heuristic.
So if we were
guaranteed, that would
be our heuristic was
godlike, like this heuristic.
If your heuristic
already tells you
the correct answer no matter
what, don't do game search.
Just go to the
empty chess board,
put all the pieces
in the front rows,
and run static
evaluator on that.
And it'll say, oh, it looks
like with this game not
started that white is stupid,
so black will win in 15 turns.
And then you're done.
And you don't do a search.
We know that our heuristic
is flawed in some way.
It could be very flawed.
If it's flawed so
badly that it tells us
a very bad result of what's
actually going to happen,
even though we think the
minimizer is going to go to H,
maybe it's wrong by a
lot and it goes to G.
It could take us up
an even worse path
and make us take longer.
Question?
AUDIENCE: If it's
the heuristic, how
could you cache the
values so you didn't
have to recalculate them later?
PROFESSOR: The question
is, how can you
cache the values if it's
a heuristic so you don't
have to recalculate them later?
The answer is, it wouldn't
help if there weren't
these weird multi-level
things where
we stop at E for some reason,
even though it goes down
to five levels.
The way you could cache
it is it is a heuristic.
But it's consistent.
And I don't mean
consistent from search.
I mean it's a consistent
heuristic in-- the game state
E is, let's say that's the
state where I moved out
my knight as the maximizer,
and the minimizer said,
you're doing the
knight opening, really,
and then did a counterattack.
No matter how we
get to E, or where
we go to get to E, that's
always going to be state E.
It's always going to have
the same heuristic value.
It's not like some guy who goes
around and just randomly pulls
a number out of a hat.
We're going to have
some value that gives us
points based on
state E. And it's
going to be the same
any time we go to state
E. Does that make sense?
It is a heuristic.
But it's always going to give
the same value at E no matter
how you got to E.
But it could be really bad.
In fact, you might
consider a heuristic
that's the opposite of correct
and always tells us the worst
move and claims it's the best.
That's the heuristic that
the minimizer program
did to our computer, perhaps.
In that case, when we do
progressive deepening and we
reorder, we'll probably get
the worst pruning possible.
We might not.
But we may.
So in that case,
you're not guaranteed.
I hope that's given a few clues.
In tutorial, you
guys are going to see
some more interesting
problems that
go into a few other details.
I at least plan on doing
[INAUDIBLE] interesting game
problem from last year, which
asked a bunch of varied things
that are a little bit
different from these.
So it should be a lot of fun,
hopefully, or at least useful,
to do the next quiz.
So have a great weekend.
Don't stress out too
much about the quiz.